talks are underway in vienna this week
to potentially return the u.s to a
landmark 2015 nuclear agreement with
iran
but those efforts could be complicated
by the country's continued imprisonment
of four americans including
international businessman ahmad
shargi in an interview you'll see only
on cbs this morning senior foreign
affairs correspondent and universe face
and nation moderator margaret brennan
spoke with the businessman's family at
their home in washington
our family has been torn apart
my husband has been taken it has been
more than
four months since bahrain sharji has
seen
her husband's face the mother of two was
at home in washington d.c in november
when she watched
news of his arrest in iran he was given
35
pages of bogus
allegations he had never seen before
and a 10-year sentence for what
this is a very good question because he
didn't even have a chance to
read these 35 pages ahmad sharji a dual
u.s and iranian citizen has been held at
iran's notorious event prison
on murky national security charges ever
since
the u.s state department says he's
wrongfully detained
the saga began two and a half years ago
during the couple's visit to see
family in tehran it's the nightmare
we're not waking up from because
it truly happened at 2 30 in the morning
when i was awoken and there were i don't
know 15
16 17 people in the house who were these
people
the interesting thing is that they were
in plain clothes
a lot of them were masked even though
there was no covet
at the time after eight months ahmad was
released
and bahrain returned to the u.s hoping
he would soon follow
but iranian authorities never let ahmad
leave and arrested him again just weeks
after president biden was elected on a
pledge
to restart diplomacy with iran i don't
know about is he being held as leverage
i just know he is an
innocent man he is the father of two
beautiful young ladies who who used to
play on this playground
here their father missed both of their
college graduations
do you have any idea why
the iranian authorities would take your
father yeah
it's because he's an american citizen i
mean they is a history of this happening
to be used as leverage you feel like
your family's stuck in the middle of
this
international crisis completely it's
just like
my dad just said dad like let him come
home we are not
your pawn we are not to be used for
a political agenda secretary of state
anthony blinken assured the shargies
and the families of the three other
american prisoners held by iran
that their return is a priority in
february the administration revealed to
cbs news that it had contacted tehran
about them
around the same time it also offered to
talk about rejoining the obama-era
nuclear agreement
nuclear talks are big and they will take
some
time but families like ours are just
these
little families living our lives just
just release a mod in the image i'm just
working towards is
having him walk through our front door
like that is all i want and that is what
i dream about him
coming home walking through the door
like surprising us and then
i wake up and it it's of course a dream
the sharji family is concerned about
ahmad's health the risk of
covid as well biden administration
officials tell me that they are doing
all that they can but
anthony it's not really clear what that
means iran's foreign minister has said
publicly the country's open to a
prisoner swap but the window of
opportunity may be closing given the
upcoming
june elections in iran well you
certainly feel for that family though
margaret we sure hope the show
you see ahmad come home thank you so
much